Oh, so going back to this
asteroid impact, oh, sorry.
There is a layer somewhere around 66
million years ago that indicates that the
Earth got hit by an asteroid. That's
what I mean. That's why I say that. Yeah.
I think it's,
the layer is high in uranium.
I think an iridium has a,
it's very rare on earth,
but very common in space and uh,
there's a bunch of other indications
that that's the time that it hit.
But what they're saying on the radio
lab one is that the current state of
understanding is that the dinosaurs and
basically most things died within the
first couple of hours. Like all the
dinosaurs, they were all apparently there.
Their bones or their fossils are in that
iridium layer a lot of times. Right.
I don't know. Maybe. Yeah. They found a
lot of, they find him before too. Right?
They don't just don't find
any after these things. Yeah.
They think that their
blood boiled in their body.
They think it got so hot that during
the few hours he got to like 700,
a thousand degrees, 1200 degrees.
It just got insanely hot.
It was trying to get better
at stand up and stand shape.
Now I gotta worry about fucking
that's a fulltime job. Raise my kids.
That's what we really
should be thinking about.
Not just how bad were
fucking the earth up,
but how bad something could fuck
the earth up from the sky. Yeah.
That's what we really should
be paying attention to.
Instead of paying attention to so
many nonsensical things that people
concentrate on,
there's a real chance that we could get
hit in our lifetime with something that
ends civilization like that.
Yeah. 100% can happen. Yep. Yeah.
I had Graham Hancock on last week and we
were going over his new book. This book.
Where is it? Isn't it right here, Jamie?
It's right there. It's fucking up.
It's excellent.
And Graham was talking about
to call the America before.
It's the evidence of civilizations
in the Americas, in North Americans,
particularly in the Amazon,
that they think that there was
millions of people live in the Amazon.
But when the European
explorers came over here,
the game smallpox and wiped out everyone.
Yeah.
And they came back hundreds
of years later. And there
was nothing. Yup. Like the,
the entire civilization way down.
I think.
I feel like in 1492 or
whatever there was that,
I think when the Spanish came up through
the Mississippi Delta, the same thing.
Yeah, same thing. Yeah.
They wiped out 90 but like a lot of people
think that the genocide of the native
Americans was just European soldiers and,
and people and settlers,
killing native Americans, which did
happen, but it was also influential.
90% of them were killed by disease.
90% like the entire population.
While they even had,
they even had certain government
policies where they're like,
do you missionaries are going out
there and trying to convert them to
Christianity.
You're giving them your diseases.
They knew that back then they knew that
they were like, you're, you're there.
They're getting sick and they're dying of,
you know,
there were all of a sudden they were like,
we're getting these colds
and people are dying.
They didn't have any resistance to that
crazy at those dirty Europeans with
their shit. Water shoots outside their
house and fucking vermin running around.
That was war of the worlds. I remember
war of the worlds, that movie,
how did they die?
They weren't ready for pathogens.
That's my whole philosophy
on we all try to be tough.
One of the things about all of us as men
or anybody is we hate to be who phone.
Horrible. So you know, I
trained and I, I stay in shape,
I eat well and I'm going to live forever.
I don't think there's
anything such thing as,
I don't think you can be
really ready for a situation,
you know,
in a bar I guess.
And then you get bit by a tick or
you get a flesh eating disease. Yeah.
And you'd die. Sure. So I don't know if
there's any way to get mercy to yourself.
Well, I mean you can protect yourself,
but you are ultimately very vulnerable.
But then this radio lab was freaking me
out about was that there's so many of
those things floating around in the sky.
I mean this is what Graham talked
about in not just this book,
but an in previous books that they think
that something slammed into the earth
somewhere in the past
that ended the ice age.
Probably wiped out at a giant chunk of
the large megafauna on North America,
led to almost instantaneous extinction
of so many different animals.
And so it goes, yeah, and so it
goes, and it can happen again.
There could be a super volcano.
There's all kinds of stuff like that.
All these fucking things,
and it makes you,
what if announced toward
was going to hit Denver?
NASA was practicing that this week.
Dan. Dan had done this before.
They've had like a practice run
using a bunch of the different,
here's the practice, run, get
in the boat, go to Australia.